hello everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is my 120 and today what I want
to talk about is how Black Friday is now
actually Black Thursday your turkey is
charred America Thursday now has become
a shopping day you know we are such a
capitalist country I love it listen
nobody loves commerce more than me
however it is really interesting to see
Black Friday slip into Thursday no
longer are you just eating and sleeping
no you're eating sleeping and now
shopping a lot of interesting metrics
from last year including 50,000 people
showing up between midnight and 5:00
a.m. up in upstate New York to an outlet
mall and now that company is expanding
this program to all 22 outlet malls that
they run also four million clicks last
year on Thanksgiving Day on major retail
banner ads throughout the Internet's
showing a huge explosion from the year
before
people are now shopping on Thanksgiving
and you know it's really going to be
interesting because I think Black Friday
is now B going to become an official
three-day holiday it's just really
really intriguing when we should be
caring and thanking we're rolling out
the cash and buying I understand it is
what it is um also what I want to talk
about just a couple of things couple
bullet points one Amazon Kindle I mean
do I really want to walk around with
something this size yes this is a Jets
cigar little box I like that I mean I'm
not sure about Amazon Kindle I'm gonna
go on it
Firefox 3.0 nobody is rooting for
Firefox more than I am
Firefox revolutionized my life I mean I
was stuck on Internet explorer what a
disaster that was Firefox came along and
just made me delicious and happy so I am
really rooting for 3.0 but we'll see I'm
hearing some slow remarks out there and
that worries me
and finally the first step to recovery
is admitting it and I'm gonna admit it
right now I kill songs I am now on 412
plays on jay-z's Roc Boys and I make
songs bleed nobody drives with me
because I play the same song over and
over and over again and I'm trying to
cure that so I'm Gary Vaynerchuk and I
play songs to their death